look at me i'm blinging son oh my god
we're kind of watching that that's very
nice there's just diamonds literally
falling off of you let me tell you story
behind this watch okay and i know a lot
of black people are going to hate me for
saying this
i'm good friends with kid rock oh no
the controversy that you are bringing to
this show
listen i'm saying black lives matter
right but i do got some white friends
and one of them is kid rock yeah kira so
a kid rock was i was oh my god texas
last week
invites me
to lunch
which i accept
oh my god i make sure that i'm wearing a
black last matter t-shirt okay that's
good just in case it gets crazy right
and he hands me this box right yeah and
i open the box and we're good we're cool
you know
he asked me this box and i open it
and it's a watch
and i open i look at the watch and the
first thing i say say the kid rock is
like
i'm not sucking your dicks
like certain gifts yeah require yeah i'm
sure recip what is reciprocation
reciprocation yes reciprocation right a
watch
um uh air force ones
um you wouldn't suck his dick for that
but if he said look would you just hold
my balls would you have done that all
right first off this is the white humor
coming up right now
because you gave me options to be
homosexual
i didn't really do that i love that by
the way and in the black community you
can you can get away with being friends
with kid rock but you can't cuff his
balls yeah he can't he can't go
and like me that's like a rite of
passage sure oh yeah how to use
creative friendship if you don't cuff
this ball 100 yeah that's what a real
friend is so
so i open the box and i'm like you know
and i made not not to say i'm a
materialistic guy but i did like this
jim i said
[Laughter]
i don't know if that makes me gay but i
said i said
did you fan yourself with your hand i
was like this i looked at him and i
and i said
you shouldn't have
okay now right yeah he's looking at my
eyes like you deserve it i'm like this
i'm not doing anything
i'll take it
right so i'm like this and i'm saying
what when did we get so close where you
could give me
watch right
so then he's like ah
he's laughing right he said yo
that watch cost me 19
what is that a fake watch
can i tell the story yes you may it's my
story i apologize it's not just no
that's true it's all right i'm out of
line i'm on your way down a little
[Laughter]
this is a crazy thing about this watch
so he's like
uh i give it to people as it's a joke
and i'm like this i [ __ ] knew i
didn't really love you
right and then i'm like but then i said
okay
it looks whatever it is i'm not a
jewelry person
so i went on stage
uh that night and i went to watch and
then anytime somebody gotta watch they
got to keep doing like this because you
got to show people yeah yeah like
community you got to do this
you got to do this let me show you guys
you got to be like right in a stack of
money right right so i'm i'm i'm flexing
on them on stage uh-huh i see the
[ __ ] queens whatever you want to call
them
they like i said i said y'all see me
shining stunting on you hoes and i was
like they was like you crazy you crazy
i'm like i said this i said boy i'm
gonna get my dick
that's right you thought you were going
to have to be i knew i knew i didn't
have to talk
yeah i could hear this sure so i'm like
this i'm like this oh [ __ ] and i'm like
yeah i i got these [ __ ] open they was
like you still be stupid and i said i'm
gonna get my dick sucked off this watch
it was like they they didn't disagree
yeah they were looking at me like okay
you could and i said right when i come
i'm gonna let you know this watch cost
me 19.99
i see how you feel about yourself right
so it's fugazi i think on stage i threw
it on stage so yesterday
i did an interview in the breakfast club
yeah um
[ __ ]
charlemagne i was going to ask about
that but
i was figuring we'd get through this
story
charlemagne he likes to test you so he
has a diamond tester
oh so i'm going and he's historically
disrespectful to you historically yes
really yes he is yes he is
okay i'm like this i'm flexing the watch
like i'm thinking i'm gonna get a joke
off the [ __ ] i'm like i'm like y'all
just see the diamonds in it like this oh
[ __ ] is that a breitling or whatever i'm
not a watch dude i don't know right
different brains or whatever but it was
something that impressed them
dj envy was looking at me like
he could get his dick sucked off
he's giving me that energy
right so i was like you can test this
[ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] so i think this
is gonna be opportunity they say who
gave me that why would we get him i said
kid rock gaming
right my man so i'm waiting for it
he tested i'm waiting for him to be like
it's fake right
he was like oh it's real i'm like what
what i don't know how to take it now i
don't know if it's real it's like
memorex it's like the wwe
i don't know if it's real whatever it's
fake but it's at least entertaining
i don't know if it was one real diamond
whatever but whatever it is
kid rock gave me this yeah and it's not
fake it might be
here's the thing maybe the test is off
here's the thing so kid rock yeah it's
my guy so i called him
yesterday to say
is this watch fake
or is it real
that's why i wanna have a conversation
sure
[ __ ] didn't take my call what
and i'm like i thought you was my [ __ ]
excuse my language but that's what i
meant right that's what he said before
yeah okay all right
[Laughter]
and they'd be like just get this [ __ ]
dick you know what i'm saying right okay
all right that's good i usually say that
about the other guy that walks in the
room while i'm [ __ ] her
right you can say like i'm not opposed
to it right right
who's i consider to be my friend
to share this story because i think you
get a kick out of
the [ __ ] called her twice
k rock doesn't answer my call oh
i'm like
i don't know what the [ __ ] is going on
yeah so then i go to his instagram page
because you know when somebody's missing
whatever you gotta go to the social
media and see where they're living
and i really i know why he didn't call
me because he just posted something that
said i was hanging out with
president number 45 or whatever
hope he's 47. um so i think he thought i
was calling him
to complain
oh about that about that
and then it really hurt my feelings
because you just want to know about the
watch i want to know about the watch i
don't know if it's real and i want to i
wanted to know where our friendship was
right you know what i'm saying because
this could cause a lot of problems with
me
i could get
a dick sucked off this watch right i
could get robbed off of it i don't need
that and i need to understand what the
purpose because i was waiting for it to
be fake so i could say this will happen
when you try to make america great again
you get black people fake watches right
but then all of a sudden it came up real
came up real we don't know
but guess what what
does it really matter no it's how people
respond to it right yeah i mean this is
the crazy thing about it i'm saying to
myself does this
materialistic [ __ ]
move people enough well they act
different
and it does because nobody knows the
fake or real i i love the fake [ __ ] you
like face i love it i don't give a [ __ ]
that's true you did your special in a
pair of fake easies i worked fake yeezys
and told everybody they were fake easies
why not 20 bucks 20 bucks on amazon did
anybody know
they probably would have from a distance
they wouldn't have
[Music]
fronted
you don't get your dick
you're honest [ __ ] you say real
[ __ ] to chicks yeah i've have i ever in
the sense of like my idea of fronting is
yeah like uh yeah this this could go
somewhere further like that's as much as
i can do you can't use that sentence son
what that's not a dick sucker sentence
this could go further yeah
no but i mean the relationship like
implying that there'd be more even worse
son you can apply the relationship on
getting your dick sucked no so you build
a relationship often get your dick side
no no but if a girl says something like
how many relationships i would be in a
lot
yeah i build a relationship
right i don't do it but i mean there's a
couple times where you're out with
somebody and you probably know this is a
one and done and you don't say i love
you but you also kind of you you yeah
maybe you kind of let it hang in the air
that it's possible and then all you know
let the connection build so that she
feels there's a shorter connection maybe
she will suck that dick yeah now first
off i feel disrespected by that because
you don't know what i identify as that's
a great point you said she that's the
not the proper pronoun for somebody you
don't know what they might they they
them they are they them dim damn
yeah
so how come charlotte means that i had
no idea you guys had a thing i don't
know him well i'm very disrespectful i
know him very casually i met him once or
twice
well the question people always ask me
is it real
or is it fake
to which i replied if you asked that
question i've done my job yeah in regard
to entertainment
it's the same principles as wwe wwf i
don't know what you say i don't know
which one it is
but
you know it's fake but it's still
entertaining